oh
elle et moi
je suis vraiment content de vous
rencontrer parce que votre répertoire
que vous interprétez me fascine et votre
histoire est intéressante vous êtes né
au liban nous est arrivé au québec à
l'âge de 6 ans et vous êtes devenu en
quelque sorte archéologues musicale oui
pourquoi vous avez fait ce choix moi je
vais vous dire quelque chose je suis un
peu le mouton noir de la communauté
libanaise pour ceux qui le savent je
chante de la musique d'avant 1920 et
c'est en 1920 que le liban s'est formé
je chante le champ du mont liban d'avant
celle qui figure sur l'album c'est une
phénicienne sur l'album alors voilà pour
dire j'ai pas oublier mon identité pour
ce qu'ils veulent mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que la musique que je chante
appartient à un temps où est ce que à ce
moment là il n'y avait pas de fair use
il n'y avait pas ces chanteurs là
[Musique]
mais
je me passionne pour cette époque qui
rassemblait d'ailleurs les turcs les
ottomans bon qui rassemblait autant les
compositeurs et venues des régions plus
du sud
donc la musique classique arabe les
iraniens qui ont contribué ils ont tous
fait cette synthèse ils ont construit
cette synthèse de la musique ottomane
entre le 14e siècle et le 19e siècle
c'était une unification et je pense que
j'appartiens plus à cette époque là dans
mon identité je suis moins nationaliste
mais en ce moment je vous avoue que je
suis en train de me dire nationaliste
avec chris
dans le fond vous faites de la musique
nous suscitons ne recherche politique la
recherche de ce temps perdu ou la
poitiers prenait beaucoup de place où
l'histoire centre mais là tout ça non je
veux dire c'est une politique malgré
tout malgré moi moi je m'intéresse pas
comme je vous dis à la politique autant
je me suis jetée dans la musique des
premiers chrétiens d'orient que la
musique abbassides des chants soufis
dans l'islam ainsi que la musique judéo
espagnole des séfarades
ils se sont tous rencontrés durant l'ère
ottomane et c'était des peuples qui cote
qui se côtoyaient dans une même musique
une même sonorité et c'est comme la
preuve de ses temples au liban qui
deviennent
des églises et ensuite qu'ils deviennent
des mosquées je vais dire tout se
transforme
et on a été les trois ans soit je crois
à travers les générations
on peut dire que notre grand père était
musulman et notre grand mère était juive
et l'autre était en arrêt je veux dire
donc tout ça saint-ernel on est une
combinaison de beaucoup de choses dans
notre culture et nos rituels
comment vous vivez cette crise qui
secoue justement le liban il ya un
soulèvement qui exige une refonte
complète du système politique
carrément oui bien sûr je veux dire le
monde est en train de se rassembler en
fin au nom des trains druzes ou un
sunnite ou chiite ou un chrétien ou un
maronite cette région toutes ces
communautés se rassemble l'ensemble du
sud au nord comme vous le voyez en ce
moment c'est une même chaîne humaine qui
a envie de renverser une corruption dont
ils en ont assez de payer le prix et qui
a 30 ans et c'est vraiment
impressionnant de voir comment certains
gouvernements entraîne son entraînement
de se retirer
la race est
mais on est tellement fort en ce moment
les libanais on enthousiasme tellement
différent même quand on se croise à
montréal je veux dire j'ai croisé des
gens consulat du liban comment on est
tous là pour pouvoir vraiment on a une
excitation vraiment de pouvoir se
rassembler en fin de dire voilà on se
prononce ça suffit ce qui m'intéresse
beaucoup dans votre travail c'est que
vous avez quitté le québec pendant
quatre ans oui pour vous rendre au moyen
orient est vraiment étudié à fond les
chants traditionnels de mehdi que votre
road c'est votre fils explication la
guerre non je blague je l'affectionnent
c'est un être que je mets contre moi que
je que j'affectionne que je verse pas là
c'est mon fils c'est toute une histoire
derrière ça vous l'avez acheté dans ceux
de la turquie
oui il ya un motif qui vous lie avec cet
instrument j'en ai un autre aussi à
l'audience deux libanais que
j'affectionne aussi beaucoup je veux
dire chacun d'eux m'apporte quelque
chose
l'instrument qu'on joue quand on le
chante avec un instrument c'est comme
notre piano nous permet d'identifier les
notes et les les micros tonalité alors
ils nous accompagnent qui nous encourage
à chanter que je veux dire c'est quelque
chose qui résonne c'est une caisse de
résonance alors elle résonne compte soit
et avec nos chansons elle nous
accompagne
je veux dire sans cet instrument je ne
sais pas comment me connecter dans mes
racines si je peux dire c'est mon
connecteurs la mairie d'arette quel
bonheur merci beaucoup
enchantée
mm